[Music]
from marvel back in their try-hard phase
the filmmaker responsible for some of
the best bad moments in superhero cinema
the guys who cranked out some of the
dumbest fun movies since they cranked
out both cranks
and the screenwriting equivalent of
herpes comes two films that feel like
going on a 48-hour coke bender with nick
cage and by that i mean they're a bad
idea but still pretty fun
i could feel him
ghost rider and ghost rider spirit of
vengeance
only one man is uniquely qualified to be
the ghost writer nick cage cause this
actor's already been an outcast who
melts his face off like a wicker man
trapped between worlds this army of one
will drive angry seeking justice when it
gets dark he'll kick ass with his kill
chains as a prisoner of the ghost land
because this lord of war is running with
the devil and he's got a score to settle
holy crappy makes a lot of movies it's
almost inconceivable what a pig or a
national treasure depending on how you
look at it
leather up with johnny blaze and ghost
rider one he's a stuntman who's more hot
rod than evel knievel
but when his dad has a light cough aka
movie speak for dying of cancer
he'll make a deal with the devil to
prolong his life for about one afternoon
[Applause]
stricken with grief teenage johnny will
ghost his sweetheart leaving her to grow
into a reporter with a 10-year age
difference and now must become the ghost
rider a demon with the powers of riding
a motorcycle which she could already do
and scaring people to death with eye
contact which again nic cage could
already do
follow up the campy original with an
edgelord reboot in ghost rider spirit of
vengeance where they change his look
supporting cast and origin story because
just shut up and embrace the chaos okay
fire piss
in the first one he made a deal with the
devil now in the follow-up he'll have an
even worse idea and make a deal with a
priest to bring him a young boy
in a sequel that abandons all restraint
and just gives the people what they want
a skull monster barfing fire bullets
into a goon's face
full of high octane visuals that almost
overcome the moment when the ghost rider
scold you for pirating movies you did
something you wouldn't want the writer
to see a white lie an illegal download
you wouldn't download a crane oh wait
you would
speed through two early comic book films
that would be pretty forgettable if it
weren't for the cage of it all as nick
brings a grab bag of random quirks to
johnny blaze like an elvis accent that
disappears after the first film you know
i watch a lot of tv and you do a really
good job only drinking straight from the
container
unless it's jelly beans in which case
martini glass
[Music]
while off camera he was bringing the
weird by doing his own makeup sewing
totems into the lining of his jacket and
then i would sew in bits of uh egyptian
artifacts that were thousands of years
old into my costume and just generally
freaking out at all times for our
entertainment
just
hunger if you want to pull that trigger
do it
at the door
screaming at the door
[Music]
but the cage won't rage alone there's a
whole cast carefully selected by the
directors for their authentic
europeanness i mean like all europeans
they just they have an accent right it's
over there in the europe it's the wrong
like idris elba as moreau a french
priest so stereotypical we were going to
make a joke like
i love it to drinks of wine but that's
more or less his actual dialogue
sam elliott as the narrator from the big
lebowski doing the kind of authentic
portrayal of the american west that he
stands for
jane campion could never
rebel wilson huh that's random a one
division fan theory video's worth of
mephistos played by one actor who has to
be in this movie because his deal with
the devil was up and one actor who has
to be in this movie for his deal with
the devil to get started plus a new
metal band's worth of unthreatening pale
demon boys look out ghost rider it's
puddle guy why dreadlocks rockabilly
twilight and the personification of mold
so return to the bad old times of 2000's
comic book movies before iron man made
them cool and no one prestiged the sh
out of everything even though real fans
know these are some of the most true to
comics films ever made not because
they're accurate because they're loud
fun and barely makes sense comics are
mostly dumb that's why we love them my
name is
[Music]
starring
daredevil what it makes more sense for
him than a blind lawyer blazing saddles
girls one eva
low gang
so man
demonic and knuckles the conjuring the
devil made me do it with him hellboy
decay hole
dentabledoor
praden
and the least realistic parts in a movie
with a flaming skull demon biker i think
i should walk you to your car you're
pretty and all but why don't you just go
back to wherever it is you came from you
think i'm pretty right
spawn in 60 seconds
okay why does roxanne bring a magic
eight ball on a date will i be in the
sequel outlook not good
keep my wife's name out of your beeping
mouth
i'm strong to the finish cause i eats me
spinach
rubber baby buggy bumpers you get to say
rubber baby buggy bumpers in arnold
schwarzenegger's voice all right honest
trailers is filmed in front of a live
studio audience
[Music]